haces un maratón de películas y cada
película dura 13 cuartos de hora es
decir una hora con tres cuartos si
deseas ver tres películas durante este
maratón qué duración tendrá tu maratón
podemos usar la siguiente recta numérica
para ayudarnos a encontrar la respuesta
y vamos a hacerlo de una manera gráfica
tenemos como primer película
la guerra de las galaxias' es una muy
buena película seguramente me gustaría
tenerla en un maratón así es que veamos
tiene una unidad de hora y tres cuartos
de hora
así es que llegamos del 0 al 1 usaremos
esto y lo marcaremos grande grande
y tenemos la primera hora y tres cuartos
de horas
aquí tenemos entre el 1 y el 2 / 4
porciones así es que tenemos ya está
dividido en cuartos vamos a tomar 3 de
ellos 1 2 3
y con eso tendremos nuestra primera
película la guerra de las galaxias'
aquí se ve en verde vamos a hacer ahora
el señor de los anillos' otra muy buena
película
vamos a contar entonces una hora que
fueron cuatro cuartos más tres cuartos
es decir tenemos siete cuartos
de hecho lo podemos contar aquí 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 una manera de decir una hora con
tres cuartos de hora es igual a decir
siete cuartos de hora así es que vamos a
marcar nuestros siete cuartos de hora
tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 o lo que es lo mismo estos primeros 4
son un entero
y estos tres corresponden a los tres
cuartos siguientes tenemos ahora dos de
las tres películas que tenemos y
finalmente vamos a colocar con
anaranjado la película de gandhi
realmente esta película dura más pero a
mí me gusta mucho es una muy muy buena
película y seguro la tendría en este
maratón
vamos a colocar entonces los siguientes
siete cuartos o una hora tres cuartos
1 2 3 4 5 6 7
llegamos con nuestra película y
marcaremos bastante bien
hemos llegado hasta 5 enteros un cuarto
este punto es cinco enteros un cuarto y
eso es lo que tardaremos viendo nuestras
películas cinco horas un cuarto de horas
esto lo hicimos de manera gráfica pero
vamos a ver qué tal sucedería si lo
hacemos desde operaciones matemáticas
veamos tendremos una hora tres cuartos
lo que es equivalente
uno entero cuatro cuartos
más tres cuartos
y cuatro cuartos más tres cuartos es
igual a siete cuartos esto ya lo
habíamos visto aquí arriba se dan cuenta
ahora vamos a tener nosotros siete
cuartos
multiplicados por tres
por las tres películas cada duración de
la película por las tres películas y
esto va a ser igual
tener siete cuartos tres veces
siete cuartos más siete cuartos más
siete cuartos vamos bien esto nos va a
dar un total de 21
cuartos o lo que es lo mismo si lo
queremos poner en números enteros
tendremos 20 cuartos que se divide
perfectamente entre cuatro más un cuarto
y este 20 cuartos realmente si dividimos
el numerador entre el denominador
tendremos que es igual a cinco enteros
un cuarto que es exactamente la misma
respuesta que tenemos aquí arriba otra
manera en la que podemos pensarlo es
tener siete cuartos
multiplicando tres enteros sobre uno con
eso tenemos tres enteros es otra manera
de representarlo y haciendo la
multiplicación podemos tener entonces
777 que es igual a 7 por 3 todo esto
entre 4
o lo que es lo mismo 7 por 3
como numerador y como denominador
tendremos 4 por 1
vamos bien esto nos dará un resultado de
21 cuartos que ya hemos visto esto
significa 5 enteros 1 cuarto y con eso
tenemos nuestra respuesta